l'office municipal de tourisme de
clermont ferrand est né en 1963 jusqu'à
cette date le tourisme dépendent est ici
d'un syndicat d'initiative de type
associative cet office municipal est de
plus en plus consulté que ce soit dans
ses bureaux par courrier ou par
téléphone
tout cela pour une clientèle de plus en
plus important et diversifié
les consultations des touristes dépasse
la seule ville de clermont ferrand
g
nous plantent leur visite
au nom des rencontres
armand mais aussi sur la région
fièrement est une ville
bass ou en visite du vieux quartier la
cathédrale à venir au bal mais tous nos
touristes sont très friands de
l'environnement et particulièrement de
la chaîne des puys la caisse qui vient
me voir et des français bien sûr mais
aussi des allemands des anglais
les suédois
nous avons aussi quelques américains des
italiens des espagnols
s'il est parfois des questions
saugrenues vous pour ces touristes lui
poser des questions sur les monuments
qui nous pose pas les questions plus
libérateur du terrain sur panne de
voiture avec des marques de voitures
tels que croit moins connu dans notre
région
des crânes également dans les camping
cars et perte de clés des gens qui
s'égarent deux voitures qui se suivent
et qui sont pu retrouver qui sont perdus
en euros est très souvent pour des
étrangers de l'office de tourisme est le
point de ralliement
lorsqu'il arrive refuge et reçus ont
plusieurs
quelles sont les qualités donc il faut
faire preuve contre travail de reprise
sur une frappe passa à l'accueil des
gens une humeur toujours égale à sourire
de réglages et quelquefois beaucoup de
sa séance un plan guide placé devant
l'office de tourisme permet des
recherches aisée grâce à des repères
lumineux six personnes travaillent à
temps plein en saison des personnels
temporaires ou stagiaires renforce
l'équipe
quatre antennes de l'office permettent
de mieux couvrir l'agglomération parmi
ces quatre celle de la place de jaude
ici a été ouverte début juin situé en
plein centre ville dans un cadre
agréable
elle reçoit beaucoup de visiteurs les
renseignements donnés ici portent sur
clermont ferrand essentiellement
autre antenne celle installée dans le
musée du ranquet en pleine zone piétonne
d'ici par les visites guidées
l'ensemble est devenu en 1922 le musée
des visites guidées individuelles ou en
groupe sont en effet organisé du 15 juin
au 30 septembre sous la conduite de
guides conférenciers ces visites sont
l'occasion d'apprendre beaucoup sur le
passé de la ville de se voir expliquer
son évolution et de découvrir une
multitude de choses que là il peut
exercer ne peut discerner une
association l'association cigales
dépendante de l'office de tourisme
permet de réaliser ces midi hors saison
avec la présence d'interprètes
lucky et homme méchant parce que nous
avons c'est l'image levé l'industriel
qui nous colle un petit peu à la france
et deschamps sont étonnés de découvrir
en fait de son
ancien des propos sévères
le centre de clermont
les centres de manquer
hormis les questions qu'on vous pose que
les seuls sur revient le plus souvent
bien que la couleur de la pierre un
niqab le mans on nous demande pourquoi
cette ville et si noir et les gens sont
étonnés par la couleur de cette pierre
qui sombre alors il faut leur expliquer
qu'elle est bien sûr d'origine
volcanique et que quand on l'extrait
n'est pas si sombre que cela elle est en
fait gris très clair
et soudain l'impression que des
touristes qui s'ennuie jamais vous a
envoyé deux des gens qui connaissent
pour visiter à leur tour la ville
les clermontois mènent souvent des
personnes qui sont en votre résistance
vacances de chez eux et bien souvent on
arrive à faire faire aux gens les deux
visites à clermont celle de clairement
celle de montferrand et parfois même on
veut les entraîner à riom qui est une
ville d'art ce proche aussi
l'office municipal de tourisme de claire
manquements met à la disposition des
touristes une série documentation
régulièrement réédité leur tirage 20000
exemplaires
pour la municipalité il faut aujourd'hui
profiter de l'ouverture de l'auvergne
sur l'extérieur
nous voudrions profiter que maintenant
l'auvergne commencent à être connues
être fréquenté le département du puy de
dome en particulier avec ses montagnes
et ses lacs et le puy-de-dôme le petit
homme puisque qui est un des sites les
plus visités de france et le non ayant
cld ou huit hommes les gens puissent
venir tant clairement et nous nous
essayons de faire connaître clairement
je dirais entre guillemets que nous
vendons aucun de nos ventes ont
clairement au travers de toutes les
manifestations que nous présente
manifestation importante ce soit de
sport sport national voire international
des cancers des cancers importants qui
permettent de guerman soit connue du
sang le plan national voire même
internationale et que les gens y
viennent
vous ne regrettez pas clairement soit
une ville de passage puisque de séjour
estompe l'inversé je pense que jusqu'à
présent la clermont n'était même pas une
ville de passage parce qu'on n'avait pas
beaucoup la possibilité de passer d'un
onglet remords a clairement puisqu'il
n'y avait pas d'autoroute le fait il y
avait des autoroutes maintenant sur
clermont et que les gens vont passer à
proximité c'est à nous de travailler
pour vous les arrêter au passage et leur
permettre de passer quelques heures d'un
haut régulièrement voir quelques jours
leur rôle au travers des congrès aussi
joué très concret c'est très important
pour nous qu'à présent nous demandions
pas les progrès nous attendions que les
congrès se présente à nous fait là on
nous recherchons en écrire et à partir
de ces congrès
c'est connu deux partants avoir vise les
1000 journée quand des congrès cette
année les gens viennent à un congrès où
la région opel et reviennent quelques
fois avec leur famille où on compare à
leurs amis